the wheel of time turns
[Music]
and ages come and pass
[Music]
leaving memories
[Music]
that become legend
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
talk about the wheel of time the new
amazon series which is an adaptation of
the massive 14 volume fantasy series by
robert jordan the first book came out
way back in 1990 unfortunately jordan
passed away in 2007 before the series
was complete his wife and editor chose
brandon sanderson to finish what turned
out to be three more novels based on the
original ending that was planned before
we get into what the story is about and
what i think would be useful to know
before you watch the tv series i just
want to make clear i'm no expert i've
only read the first three novels so far
after struggling a little bit to get
into the first one i'm pretty invested
in it at this point i think i got a
pretty good grasp on how the series
opens but i don't know how it ends and
i'm really in no hurry to get there i
have no intention of finishing it and
trying to absorb the whole thing before
the show comes out as a new fan most of
what i've seen in relation to the
trailers is geared towards a level of
obsessiveness that i haven't reached yet
so i wanted to make a video for the
uninitiated people who haven't read the
books and aren't sure what to make of it
there will be light spoilers in the way
of background information but i won't be
giving away anything important as far as
how the first season will develop or how
it might end with the trailer we also
got the release date for the show on
friday november 19th the first three
episodes will be available and then
there will be weekly episodes for the
next five weeks finishing off the eight
episode first season there's also going
to be at least one more season as season
two's already been ordered and they're
filming it right now
what is the wheel of time then the
official summary from amazon describes
it like this the wheel of time is one of
the most popular and enduring fantasy
series of all time with more than 90
million books sold set in a sprawling
epic world where magic exists and only
certain women are allowed to access it
the story follows maureen a member of
the incredibly powerful all-female
organization called the eyes to die as
she arrives in the small town of two
rivers there she embarks on a dangerous
world-spanning journey with five young
men and women one of whom is prophesized
to be the dragon reborn who will either
save or destroy humanity in the author's
words the idea was born from the
question what would it be like to be
tapped on the shoulder and told you were
going to save the world but also destroy
it a simple overview then is that it's a
story of good versus evil there is a
chosen one element there's a group of
normal folks swept up into an adventure
that has incredible stakes and magic is
a regular part of this world but it's
controlled by this exclusive group of
women and we see them quite a bit in the
trailer you'll notice that in the tv
show they all wear different colors to
indicate the different sub-societies
that exist inside their organization
which is called the i sedai the
subgroups are called ajos and there's
seven of those each with its own purpose
and rules what sets the eyes to die
apart from everyone else is their
ability to channel what's called the one
power if their ability is recognized
they'd be taken to this place called the
white tower and the city tar ballon
where they can be trained to harness the
power without hurting themselves or
others not everyone that has the spark
or the ability can actually become an
eye sedai and there's a whole process to
it where they start out as novices and
then they advance to being accepted
until they pass the test to become a
full acid eye and pick their asha
there's a good reason why only women are
allowed to channel the male side of the
power has been tainted which i'll come
back around to and any male that uses it
ultimately goes insane and causes a lot
of problems in the process to deal with
this the i said i use a process called
gentling which means cutting the man off
from the one power permanently in the
trailer we see one of these men with the
i said i trying to capture him his name
is logan and he is a character from the
books whose story it looks like they
extended some for the show in order to
explain how this stuff works we also see
what are called trollocks and a murder
all these are shadows spawn they're
creatures that are basically of the dark
one and i guess in the beginning what's
important to know about them is that
they wreak havoc wherever they show up
we see that happening in the trailer in
this small village of emmons field where
most of the main characters come from
it's mostly cut off from the outside
world beyond the merchants that come to
trade and sell things to the locals the
inhabitants are mostly farmers and
tradesmen living in a tight-knit
community where everyone's somewhat
distrustful of outsiders fans often
refer to the main characters you meet
here as the emmons field five rand is a
sheepherder matt is kind of the local
prankster perrin is a blacksmith's
apprentice aguain is the mayor's
daughter and naive is the village wisdom
the wisdom is the local healer and
leader of the women's circle which is an
important role in the village things are
governed by two groups the village
council made up of men and the women's
circle the wisdom is the female
equivalent of the mayor and a system
where both of these groups have an equal
amount of power in the trailer you see
the icidi moraine arrive with her water
land and then you see that they get into
a battle with shadow spawn that arrive
right after them this starts off the
adventure as moraine was there looking
for someone who might fulfill the
prophecy of the dragon reborn and
assumes the dark ones forces were there
for the same reason she believes they
were there looking for rand matt or
perrin and takes them from the city in
an effort to protect them i don't want
to get too much deeper into the lore in
this video but as i mentioned at the
beginning it is a battle of good and
evil where there's a creator who brought
the universe into existence along with
the wheel of time which they say spins
the pattern of the ages using the lives
of men and women as its threads there's
also an antithesis to the creator called
the dark one he was in prison keeping
him away from the wheel but basically
over time he starts to break free and is
trying to take over long before the
beginning of this story the wheel
reacted by creating the dragon to be a
champion for the light the prologue of
the first book of the series introduces
him and the end of his story and then
the prophecy says that he will come
again and that's who the dragon reborn
is
moraine thinks it could be one of these
three young men and it's important
because the dragon reborn is necessary
to go up against the dark one i'm really
simplifying all of this stuff because
it's not really that important in the
beginning as you can see there's a lot
going on but you don't need to
understand it all going in hopefully the
show will be able to bring it all to
life and they'll have enough time to do
it the setup itself is really
straightforward
a group of people from a nowhere village
find out they might be super important
and get whisked away on an adventure by
someone who's powerful with the magic
because of what happens they feel like
it's their only choice but at the same
time they're all pretty reluctant or
even hostile really and i know it sounds
really familiar and that's kind of what
made it hard for me to get into the
first book but then things do take some
interesting turns and it just keeps
going from there because men can't
channel and the eyes to die are tasked
with enforcing that there's a natural
shift in the power dynamics that gives
the world a different feel this also
creates a situation where people accept
the eyes to die as necessary but fear
them more than anything else and boy do
they have a lot of power even beyond the
fact that they can perform magic the
emmons field gang would have grown up
thinking that they were suspicious and
then they get pulled out of their
village and their lives and find
themselves thrown into this crazy
situation there's this whole dynamic of
the wheel and the cyclical nature of the
ages and then people being able to
affect how things play out it gets
pretty fascinating as the characters
learn more about it the trailer looks
promising and i think there's real
potential for an exciting adaptation
there's a couple of things that look
different but then there's plenty that
looks like it does what i read justice
and really nothing that makes me
question what they're trying to do i
think in something like this the world
building is what's tough and i hope
they're able to pull that off the voice
over in the trailer refers back to the
opening of the first book which gives
you a peek into the mystery of the world
it reads the wheel of time turns and
ages come and pass leaving memories that
become legend legend fades to myth and
even myth is long forgotten when the age
that gave at birth comes again in one
age called the third age by some an age
yet to come an age long past a wind rose
in the mountains of the mist the wind
was not the beginning there are neither
beginnings nor endings to the turning of
the wheel of time but it was a beginning
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments if
you have any questions what you thought
about the trailer please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon
you